I started telling you last week about
this idea of the voyage to the
underworld and I want to tell you a
little bit more about that.
You in particular conceptualize the
voyage to the underworld as a journey
into the unconscious and the unconscious
for the psychoanalyst is a place of
fantasy and dream and implicit
presupposition and habit and that's all
correct.
You know,
we,
there is an unconscious and it's
perfectly reasonable to conceptualize it
that way,
that the big difference I think between
the psychoanalysts and the later more
empirical scientists is that the cycle
analyst sort of envisioned your psyche
as a place of living partial
personalities instead of cognitive
computational systems.
You know,
they,
they took into account the fact that
you're alive and that the parts of you
are alive and you know there's,
there's a neuroscientist named
[inaudible].
I don't know how to say his name,
Gaza,
Nigga.
That's wrong because that is adding guy.
Yeah,
I think that's it.
Anyways,
he did some of the earliest experiments
on split brains and so sometimes if you
have intractable epilepsy,
which I wouldn't recommend by the way,
I'm one of the surgical procedures for
mediating its negative effects is
something called a,
you cut the corpus callosum and it's
very large,
very large structure in the brain that
connects the two separate hemispheres.
And No,
it's not obvious why we have two
separate hemispheres,
although I'll tell you a little bit
about why I think it is,
but anyways,
they do communicate.
And uh,
what [inaudible] demonstrated was that
you could tell one hemisphere something
without the other one knowing that both
hemispheres we're conscious and that the
consciousness was somewhat independent.
It really strange.
It's very interesting.
Makes very interesting readings,
reading,
you know,
because it suggests that fragments of
ourselves,
you could think of,
you have fragments of yourself within
you that are like low resolution
representations of you,
you know,
and the,
and the psychoanalysts would think of
those more as they're kind of like,
they're kind of like one I giants.
That might be a way of thinking about
it.
If you were thinking about it in a
fantastical way,
so there's the angry you and you know
you've all come in contact with the
angry you.
It's a rather rigid.
That's the first thing you might say
about it.
It's impulsive and short term.
It doesn't think much about the past
unless it's bad things about whoever
you're angry at,
in which case it thinks about them a
lot.
It's not too concerned with longterm
future consequences and mostly at wants
to be right and you know when angry you
disappears and normal,
you assuming such a thing exists
reappears.
You can be perfectly shocked about how
angry you behaved and in fact sometimes
if angry you really gets out of hand
like it might in a battle and a war.
It might do things that you just can't
imagine that you would do and under
those circumstances you can reveal parts
of yourself to yourself that are so
foreign and so horrifying that it will
leave you with posttraumatic stress
disorder because it is the case that
many but not all.
People who suffer from post traumatic
stress disorder,
especially if it's battlefield related,
get it because of something they did
rather than something they saw or
something that happened to them.
And that's really worth thinking about.
You know,
I mean there's a lot of weird potential
nested inside people and you know,
you don't see it under normal
circumstances because the circumstances
are normal and part of the reason that
we liked the circumstances to be normal
is precisely so that we don't see those
parts of people.
We don't want to see.